[Music]
thousands of indigenous Ecuadorians from
all over the country called for justice
for a middle-aged man killed during a
national strike on Thursday
Ecuador's people's Ombudsman says he was
one of five people killed in more than a
week of protests there's an abuse of
police force and we've also asked the
government to lift the state of
emergency which has generated more
violence I think the government has lost
control of the situation inside people's
cultural center building leaders of
Ecuador's indigenous Confederation
paraded eight policemen on to the stage
the colonel in charge told Al Jazeera
had come to negotiate the release of a
patrolman who'd been detained but they
were not allowed to leave until hours
later
[Music]
[Applause]
but indigenous leaders have stopped
short of asking for president Lenny
Marino's ouster they are demanding
instead the immediate end to what they
call police repression the release of
all detainees and the immediate
resignation of the defense and the
interior ministers as a precondition for
a dialogue with authorities the Interior
Minister is being blamed for police
firing tear gas into a university where
women children and elderly people had
taken refuge we bought our children
because we have no one to care for them
but you Interior Minister a woman are an
assassin president Moreno is refusing to
give in to demands to restore fuel
subsidies which he removed in exchange
for a five billion dollar IMF loan but a
former assembly deputy says Ecuador
can't afford desperately needed credit
moreno has to be able to negotiate with
international banks and make them
understand that we are a country with an
enormous political crisis that we cannot
be treated as though we have a stable
democracy that needs a small fiscal
adjustment here an adjustment can bring
down the whole deck of cards
indeed Ecuador has a history of
governments being toppled for a lot less
something few people here have forgotten
you see a human al Jazeera Quito